I don't think voters necessarily have to
be loyal to a person right I think
president Trump has earned a lot of
respect and a lot of appreciation from
the voters and that's why they're going
to vote for him tonight and across the
country but when when Laura lummer I
think when she's talking about the
Loyalty I think she's talking about
people like Aranda Sanz who was a
backbench congress member until he got
in his hands and knees and cried in
front of trump begging him for his
endorsement basically getting the
coronation to become governor of Florida
president Trump worked with him made
sure he got in he got rally after rally
after rally santis was running TV ads
you know basically saying you know I'm
president Trump's number one guy and you
know build the wall reading Trump books
to his kids and he embraced a trump
Brant to become who he is today and then
he totally ditched Trump uh when it
became politically convenient for him